there are still so many unknowns about
how this virus is transmitted how it
attacks the body and why some people die
and others show no symptoms we all want
answers but what we've got right now are
lots of questions tonight we explore
some of the big ones
we'll keep living in this new reality
with the threat of the virus lurking as
long as it keeps outsmarting us it's
still moving faster than our best
scientists leaving us chasing many
unknowns even one of America's most
experienced infectious disease experts
dr. Anthony Fauci who had studied HIV
and Ebola says the novel coronavirus is
his worst nightmare like oh my goodness
when is it gonna end it really is very
complicated so we're just at almost the
beginning among the biggest questions is
who who has it how many people have
actually been infected we don't know
that at all the mystery of the
asymptomatic the so-called silent
spreaders is confounding people infected
with a virus who never show any symptoms
and could be fueling the pandemic
without knowing it one of the reasons
why kovat has been such a successful
virus it's able to fill people's lungs
and have them expel that and spread it
without feeling sick in that sense it's
it's one of the most frightening viruses
that I could think of frightening and
the subject of intense debate on Monday
a top doctor at the World Health
Organisation's seemed to dismiss a
symptomatic spread it still appears to
be rare that an asymptomatic individual
actually transmits onward by Tuesday
after pushback from many epidemiologists
she clarified what she meant what we
need to better understand is how many of
the people in the population don't have
symptoms and separately how many of
those individuals go on to transmit to
others it's perplexing and needs much
more research but some initial studies
show between 25 to 45 percent of
infected people have no symptoms
poor doctors in Canada are noticing it I
am doctor named G Taz Lehmann in G is an
emergency room physician at Humber River
Hospital in Toronto so first of all have
you had any fevers no no fever chills
every patient who arrives here is
screened for Kovan 19 symptoms so
whenever we see a patient we're thinking
about the different potential diagnoses
now kovat 19 is a part of almost every
one of those lists of possibilities that
you're thinking about in your head when
you're trying to help a patient because
it presents it presents in different
ways and because we know that there are
people that don't have any symptoms
related to kovat 19 at least not on our
typical list of symptoms that we'll
still test positive patients who come in
for other reasons with no apparent Co
bed symptoms are testing positive it's a
virus that's unpredictable some patients
have no symptoms and we've seen that
like we've been surprised with some
patients that came in with a hip
fracture and have no symptoms of kovat
at all but are positive it's still
believed people who were most infectious
are those with serious respiratory
symptoms but the possibility of silent
invisible spread persists and will only
be revealed through widespread repeated
testing if you just rely on testing
people who come forward the symptoms
you're going to miss a very large number
of people with the disease and they're
the ones driving community spread a huge
chunk of this is getting a hold of
people who are transmitting before they
know they're transmitting what in what
ways is Kovac 19 attacking the body and
confounding doctors in the ICU dr. Jamie
Spiegelman has seen firsthand the myriad
of ways kovat 19 can bombard the human
body this is not just a respiratory
illness it starts as a respiratory
illness we've seen heart failure from it
we've seen kidney failure from it it
affects every organ so it's clearly a
systemic disease studies in the US and
the UK suggests more than a third of
kovat 19 patients who end up in ICU
experienced kidney failure well we've
noticed in our ICU
as patients that go on dialysis who get
renal failure from this however way
worse outcomes most of those patients
from our experience die it's as dramatic
a range is that some get only mildly ill
others die it's a mystery why in some
people the virus drives the immune
system into overdrive the body starts to
attack its own cells so we know that
most of the sickness of the things that
kill you and make you very very sick is
actually your body responding so your
immune response to this assault on your
system is the thing that makes you go to
the hospital the cytokine storm we call
it and for those who make it through
there could be lasting harm but we have
been discovering that when COBIT is able
to really get into you systemically
it causes damage in the heart it causes
damage in the liver it causes damage to
the kidneys it's why testing people
already dealing with other diseases is
vitally important and this is also why
you're seeing now a more rigorous
testing in populations certainly in the
populations of people that have kidney
disease that are dialysis patients where
where is the virus headed how is it
mutating we don't know it's mutation
rate really and in fact if it's mutating
in one direction or another all viruses
mutate the mystery is what's the novel
coronavirus doing how fast is it
changing and could it become more
dangerous or less it mutates less
frequently than the influenza virus on
average I've seen estimates of one to
two mutations per month and these
mutations are important to track early
signs are tending to the positive in
this respect the forces of evolution
might lean in our favor the nature of
mutation is that selective pressure is
put upon it by the environment determine
which mutations thrive so there is a
theory these pathogens mutate towards
lesser lethality
when when can we assume we are immune to
it or can we in the absence of a vaccine
immunity is emerging as a potential key
to resuming normal life it's hoped those
who have had kovat 19 are now immune to
it but that's all it is hope there is no
evidence behind this and why why are
some people hit hard by it and others
barely get sick
some people do well and recover and not
get that sick whereas other people might
get very very sick with this infection
who otherwise are of the same age men
seem more vulnerable children seem less
so though some are developing a
mysterious multi-system inflammatory
syndrome we've seen centenarians survive
and healthy young adults succumb why are
these people not sent American why other
people are so symptomatic that they end
up on life support machines niceyou so
we don't completely understand that as
well it's not like the virus is any
different so there must be some genetic
predisposition scientists are searching
for genetic signs that might help
explain the extreme variations in
vulnerability one study zeroed in on
regions of the human genome that could
be associated with a higher risk of
respiratory failure the same study found
a 50% increase in patients with type A
blood were in need of oxygen or a
ventilator I've heard one person call
this the dark matter of immunity while I
have some populations been resistant and
others have been explosive it's not just
about the age demographic and this might
be a good thing it might mean that we
each herd immunity sooner it might mean
that the ceiling for explosiveness of
this disease is lower than we thought
but again it's a mystery how how will
this end or are we going to be living
with the novel
Rhona virus for a long time no one alive
today has lived through a pandemic like
this we're not used to such uncertainty
unable to plan for the next month the
next year we will adapt and we will keep
learning I don't expect to be afraid of
this disease by this time next year that
won't be because of a vaccine it'll just
be because we will know better how to
treat it and people need not die of it
at the same rate that they're dying now
maybe it will turn out better than we
feared but we need to confront the
possibility some things may turn out
worse than we hoped this Chicago woman
in her 20s recovered from kovat 19 but
it devastated her lungs and she
underwent a double lung transplant which
raises another lingering question is
what happens when you're infected and
you get serious disease and you recover
what are the long-term durable negative
effects of that infection we don't have
enough experience because we've only
been involved in for months
[Music]